[Applause]  i don't know i'm a mess doesn't help  that i'm an introvert any introverts  here  oh hey all right you guys rarely speak  up yeah  not fun being an introvert no one gets  us i was in an uber once the guy's like  so you're an introvert talk about that  i'm like well that's not really how it  works  yeah  it's tough it's hard to be around people  all the time day jobs now how you guys  do it nine to five eight hours with this  group then five o'clock rolls around  some guy goes hey we should all get  drinks what are you insane you want to  hang out more we're done we did it  we're outside the walls let's go home  yeah we like being alone we do you ever  go got to eat with the guys like hey  look at that dude sitting by himself  you're like i know live the dream